for a year of my life I lived in a cabin  in the woods without any running water  plumbing or electricity  I sang opera for five years I can sing  an Italian German and French I have six  tattoos they all have meaning to me and  they remind me every day of what matters  most in life I once swallowed my tongue  piercing and I on a nine millimeter gun  when I was a kid I was a competitive arm  wrestler and spent my Sunday's dirt  biking through the woods I have around  15 tattoos I've kind of stopped counting  but I really enjoy it because it's a  cool way to commemorate certain parts of  my life permanently on my body I once  went to Spain for the sole purpose of  being chased by a herd of bulls my  senior year of high school I was  suspended for three days and banned from  my senior prom I have seven tattoos and  I like them because they make me look  tough until I open my mouth